hi everyone welcome my name is ying liu
today i'm gonna present you one of our
recent works
which is called hierarchical deep
learning of multi-scale differential
equation time staffers
and this is a joint work with my
advisors nathan curse and steve brunton
so after this video if you are
interested in this work
you are more than welcome to check out
our archive and also my github page
for more details of this project
okay so before entering the main context
of this paper
i'm gonna i'm gonna to briefly talk
about
two different regimes of dynamics
modeling
okay so traditionally when we try to
understand the dynamics
what we usually do is basically say
we want to derive a set of differential
equations first
while some first principles for example
for this pendulum
we're going to use like newton's law
which will give us like a set of
equations that
that describe the dynamics here
and after we have a set of differential
equations
we are interested in the solutions of
such equations
but since most of the interesting
dynamics are non-linear in nature
and these equations do not admit closed
form analytical solutions
and that's why we often use the
computers to run simulations on them
and there are a bunch of timestamping
schemes
for us like prepared in the field of
numerical analysis to help us
run simulations on these systems for
example one of the most
popular time stepping scheme is the
fourth order rangakata scheme
which has a local truncation error of o
delta t
to the fifth order the reason why it's
called the fourth order rungcata is
because like the global error
it's o delta t to the fourth
however here i want to point it out that
for this simulations we conduct
each step we're gonna have some small
error
although the error would be small if you
choose this delta t
to be very small however these
errors will inevitably accumulate as you
do the simulations
so this problem makes
the simulation of these chaotic systems
very challenging
why for example this lorenz system
these chaotic systems are very sensitive
to the initial conditions any
discrepancies
in the initial time frame will be
exponentially expanded
and cascaded to the future that's the
problem
okay now let's talk about the second
regime
the second regime is about like
when we try to model more complex
dynamics for example the human brain
nowadays
it's really really not easy to derive a
set of
governing equations by some first
principles
right so what we're going to do with
this system is that
we're going to collect the experimental
data from it
we record the brain activities
and the data typical typically looks
like the following
okay we have a bunch of recordings
indexed by the superscript i here
and you can see like in this data set we
have n recordings
and for each recording we have p
snapshot or p plus one snapshot in it
right x t x t plus delta t all the way
down to x t
plus p delta t so these are time series
our goal is to convert this
scientific measurement data into some
sort of model
maybe not in the form of differential
equations
but still we hope this model could be
predictive
so that we can run for example some time
stepping scheme on it
to do the predictions so that's the
setup
of the second region of like the
modeling the dynamics
this is more like a data-driven modeling
regime
so in our work there are a bunch of like
methodologies for doing data-driven
modeling for dynamical systems um
for example like the methods based on
sparse regression or symbolic regression
etc and etc but for this work we're
going to focus on
using the artificial neural network to
model the dynamics
okay there are a bunch of advantages and
disadvantages of using neural network
uh against the others uh i would name uh
for example uh the advantage of using
neural network is that um
personally i think you can deal with the
experimental data directly
without computing any numerical time
derivatives
so it's quite robust like with respect
to the data
right okay so now let's talk about
neural network so what we're going to do
is to use the neural network to model
what we call the flow map
but what is the neural network the
neural network is very simple it's
basically a function parametrized by
some parameters theta there
okay and you have the x
as the input of the neural network and
once you feed x to the neural network it
will give you some output wise
so it's that simple so what's special
about this
neural network function is that it is
compositional in nature
it is a like a sequence of operations
and for each block operation it's
basically a linear operator
followed by a nonlinear activation
function so
yeah this is what the neural network is
and to use the neural network to model
the measurement data or the sequence
data
what we're going to do is basically we
take the data here
the d here and we assume it comes from
some autonomous system in this form
which is an initial
value problem and our goal is to learn
the delta t lag flow map with this
neural network
okay so you can see that uh
finally once this neural network is
trained
the goal is that if you fit this neural
network with
xt the state variable at time point t
is going to give you the prediction uh
at the
time point t plus delta t so that's why
i put a
like a hat here you can see this because
this is a prediction
not the real value okay okay
once these neural network are trained
okay uh how we're gonna use it
so we're gonna feed the initial
snapshot x0 to the neural network and
it's going to generate
some predictions x delta t right
and this x dot d prediction will be
the input of the next run which will be
fitted back to the neural network again
and then it gives you the prediction at
time point
two delta t and then so on and so forth
you get like uh x2 data t
here and also x3 delta t so on so forth
so this seems to be very similar
to what we have with
the physics-based simulation models
where you fit
the algorithm with the initial value
then with some sort of timestamping
scheme you can
go away like all the way to the future
but the question here is that um
is that is that the best we can do are
there any problems with it
okay so the problem is that
very similar to what we have in the
classical numerical simulation settings
we have the error accumulations at each
step
okay you might say okay this is not a
big problem we had that
like in the numerical simulation
settings
why should we worry about that it's
because we're now
thinking about doing data driven
modeling which is
completely different and we have a way
to eliminate this error accumulation
somehow okay and this brings us
like to the key methodology of our work
so this picture basically shows you like
the big picture
of our methodology what we're gonna do
is to say instead of training one
neural network to do timestamping as i
previously showed
how about we you know like trim multiple
neural network
with different size of delta t's and
then
somehow combine them to do the time
stepping
simultaneously okay so so that's the
basic idea so in this example here
we have illustrated an example with
three neural networks
and you can see the red neural network
is associated with
like this big delta t1 here the time
step is very large
and the yellow neural network here it's
has some sort of like inter like an
intermediate
value of delta t2 right and this
blue network there has some like small
delta t here
you can see that right this is very
small they are associated with
different time stepping size now
consider uh
once these neural networks are trained
how do we do the predictions
of the like the state variable at time
point t which is shown in green there
how do we do the predictions there once
we feed
our algorithm with the initial
state x0 here here
okay so what we're gonna do
is basically to do timestamping for four
times you can see we can do one step
one big step with this red network
and then a step with the yellow network
and then two steps here with the blue
networks and then finally
we got to xt so meaning like we only do
four time stepping to get there
if you don't have this rad network and
this yellow map network if you only have
this blue network
what you're going to do is basically
starting from this x0
you do the timestamping again and again
and again
very slowly with some like very small
time steps you're gonna imagine you can
imagine that
if you do this the error will accumulate
along the way
so that once you get to xt actually
your predictions you know may not be
valid at all
so that's the key intuition of our
method we trim multiple networks
and we use them simultaneously so
here the red neural network can march
forward very fast
and this is the key to prevent the error
accumulation when you do time stepping
with these models
and the blue neural network is
responsible for more accurate local
predictions
what do i mean by that so like let's
consider the case where we only have the
red network
but we don't have the yellow and blue
ones if you want to go
from x0 just a little bit more like
to the future maybe to here if you only
have the
red network the best you can do is
basically to take
the x0 here and also
the first step stays here and you do an
interpolation
to estimate uh what's the state variable
here
you basically achieve that with the you
know the interpolation
and that's not going to be accurate
because
nothing's like basically guarantee you
the accuracy there
so that's where the blue network gonna
help
the blue network gonna complement this
because the blue network can
beco because the blue network can just
shoot you just a little bit away from
where you were at and then you can get
information there
so that's how we couple these two
different scale networks
okay so by coupling different scale
networks
we actually got a very like a bonus
point
um in addition to that timestamping
accuracy
uh the bonus point is that um we
somehow circumvent the explode
exploding vanishing grading problem when
we do the training of such networks
why is that because like typically
when people try to do time stepping
using the neural networks they go for
the
recurrent neural networks and when you
train the recurrent neural networks you
will have
an objective function like something
looks like this
okay this objective function it's a mean
square error
of your prediction and the ground truth
okay and you suck you basically you need
to run over
all the samples or all the recordings
that's
what this i from one to n is and also
you want to run through all the steps j
from one to p
okay you can see like the j basically
index like
um the future steps you're gonna you're
gonna make
if you want your single scale neural
network to predict
very far from the future you'd better
choose a large p
to trend this right for example p might
be a hundred
or a thousand but this gonna give you
the exploding and vanishing grading
problem when you do the training
because you basically what you do is to
say
we apply this neural network again and
again and again
the superscript j here uh means like
you apply the neural network for j times
when you
apply this for a lot of times then
when you try to use the back propagation
to compute the gradient
these gradients will typically vanish or
explode
depending on the eigenvalues of that
system
okay so that that's the problem but if
you
are using our proposed uh
methodology here you don't have this
problem why
because when you train each individual
neural network
you actually don't need a very large p
there
okay think about a problem where we want
to predict from like the
from t equals to zero to t equals to
eight
if you only have the blue network you
probably need to
train a blue network with p equals to
eight here
so that like when you do the prediction
um the prediction at the a-step may
still be accurate
but with our network okay with this
three network for example this blue one
is associated with one time step the
yellow one with two time step
and the red one with four time steps
what you need to do is basically
training these neural networks
with p equals to two because this
red neural network will handle like the
longer scale prediction you only need to
go
forward for two steps to get to t equals
to 8
with this red one and like the blue one
only needs to focus on its own range of
interest
to go two steps forward that's all we
need to do
so yeah that's how we circumvent the
exploding and vanishing gradient problem
with this
architecture now let's talk about some
results from this what i have just
told you about are just some intuitions
of that
like proposed architecture and how that
can be achieved
these are the actual accuracy we have
obtained in our paper
there are a lot of information clearly
in this class
and let's see it like column by column
so the first
three columns are very simple the first
column
are the toy non-linear differential
equation examples
that we used in our experiment
and the second columns are the
corresponding
phase space of these systems
the third column in the third column
basically we visualize
some specific trajectories of these
systems
with um like blue and red curves okay
and on top of that the the black dots
basically represent
uh the time stepping or or the
predictions that we
generated using our multi-scale
hierarchical deep learning scheme
you can see basically the agree pretty
well except for the lorenz system
so yeah for this plot what i really want
you to focus on
is actually the last column so the last
columns are the plots for the
error curves the horizontal axis
represents the simulation time and the
vertical axis
actually represents that the error in
the logarithmic scale
and different colors represent
like the different error curves for
different
methods for the colored ones you can
refer to the top panel here
for example that purple one that
represents the error curve
when we only use the neural network with
delta t equals to one dt
so what the error looks like that's the
blue curve in each example
and so on and so forth and most
importantly the black
curve is basically the coupling results
when you use all the neural network you
couple them together what is the error
curve you achieve
by using this so you can see the
black curve is well below all the single
scaled
error curves which means by coupling
different scale
neural networks you can gain like better
accuracy
by doing like for predicting the future
uh another thing i want to mention is
that you might ask
why this error curve looks so strange
you can see there's like jungling curves
there
a lot of like for example this a lot of
local minimum here why it the arrow
curve looks
this way in general it is because like
when you train a neural network for
example with delta t
it only gives you very accurate
predictions over the time point
which are the interp the multiples of
this delta t's
okay within for example zero and delta t
what we do is basically do a linear
interpolation
to achieve those predicted values that's
why
like within zero and delta t or delta t
to two delta t you can see there's like
a bomb
of the error curves that's why it looks
this way
anyways the key takeaway here is that
this hierarchical scheme
of using different scale networks can
basically bring us the accuracy for
doing the time stepping
so that's pretty much for the accuracy
let's now talk about the efficiency
okay so are there any
benefits in terms of the computational
speed
by using our method it turns out yes
why is that so before when we think
about like doing the numerical time step
stepping what we usually do is basically
we start from the
initial time frame here and then we
simulated step by step you know a little
bit
and then all the way down to the future
but right now
you can do the following we take the
initial
state variable and we fit it to the
largest scale network which is
represented by this red one
and it will output two state variables
at here and here okay
so it can go very far away to the future
and once you get the state variables on
that two
red bars you can collect them and
on the second level then you can
basically take this
initial condition the white one again
and also
the c variable at this first red bar
which is in the middle
and feed them to the yellow network this
will
separately generate like this four
yellow bars here you can see that right
okay so what i want to tell you that
actually when you do the second level
time stepping you can actually
send these two states to different
computers if you are working with for
example
a distributed memory system right so
you can do parallelization in this
computation
right now like the time stepping schemes
are not serialized in nature
anymore we can paralyze this computation
um naturally so that's the key takeaway
and also when you finish with the second
level you get those
yellow bars you can gather them with the
red bar and the
white bar again and send it to the like
the smallest scale network
which represented by this blue one and
they will give you the
simulation values or the time stepping
values at those blue bars
so after this step three you will get
all the state variables at different
bars with different colors here and in
the end
what you're going to do is basically
take all the state variables
and rearrange them so that they're in a
chronic order
so that's how we do the simulation with
this kind of data driven models
and it can be paralyzed in nature
what's more interesting is that the
similar
idea can be used to benefit
the classical numerical timestamping
schemes as well
how we going to do that think about a
scenario
where we want to simulate a
super large uh differential equation
online
okay it's of high dimensional very hard
to simulate
but we want to do it online what i'm
gonna suggest
is basically saying okay first you're
gonna do it
a bunch of simulations offline with
different initial conditions
then you collect those data and use
those data to train
a large-scale neural network
and then when you go online you want to
do some
real-time simulations what you're going
to do is to first
feed that initial condition to the
neural network first
not just like run the simulations
directly you feed the neural network
first
and this neural network gonna gives you
two state variables
by doing the time stepping it will give
you the two type
like the state variables represented by
that
two red bars there right which
corresponds to here
and there okay so these two
so this step is very cheap you just use
the neural network
and do two-step step like time stepping
there but what you have
achieved is that you break this
computation
into different different parts and
different parts can be conducted
like the simulation of these parts can
be conducted
independently on different computers so
you can parallelize
these computations using some for
example the runge-kutta 45 time stepper
in this example all right you maybe
you can send this white bar state
variables to a computer and this red bar
in the middle to another then you run
like the typical simulations you you you
typically run on a single computer but
these computations can be paralyzed
in the end you will also gonna gather
these blue bars and then
rearrange them so that they are in a
quantico order
so that's what we call the hybrid
timestampers it can be used
to accelerate classic numerical
simulations
okay now let's see some results uh
in terms of the efficiency okay and
in this plot actually there are two
plots here there are a bunch of
dimensions
a lot of information in this
illustration as well
so first we want to pay attention to the
color
so in both of these plots different
colors represent
the different non-linear system the toy
examples that we have
done the experiment on for example let's
focus on this hyperbolic
system which represents uh by this
like blue dots and blue stars and blue
curves there
okay and then let's take a look at the
left plot
so what the left plot tells you is that
we
compare all the single scale
neural network time steppers against the
multi-scale neural network
hierarchical time stepper that we just
talked about
previously okay because like the circle
represents the single scale
neural networks and the star represents
the multi-scale neural networks
you can basically see like in this plot
the
horizontal and the vertical axis are
basically the simulation time and error
they're all in logarithmic scale and in
general
these stars are well below
these curves okay meaning
our hierarchical scheme can be both
accurate and efficient okay
so so that's the takeaway from this if
you are like compared with all the
single scale neural network
the hierarchical multi-scale neural
network scheme
is both efficient and accurate
so what about the second plot so for the
second plot
uh what we are comparing are the
single time scale rangakata time
steppers
we run a bunch of simulations with
different delta t's
with the rangakata 45 that timestamping
scheme
and those are represented by this like
the triangles
in this plot and we also use the scheme
that we presented in the previous slides
which is the hybrid time stepper
which is basically built a
neural network time stepper on top of
the same
runge-kutta timesteppers we want to see
are there any
efficiency gain from it what we see
is that in general these hybrid
timestampers
are on the top left you see it's on the
top left
over this single scale longer quad
timestampers
meaning they are definitely more
efficient yeah we have this
efficiency gain but we sacrificed a
little bit on accuracy
so that's the key takeaway but i want to
point out that actually it's
really not a fair comparison right
because like
for philosophical reasons we consider
our differential equations to be the
ground truth
and in our hybrid time step probably
first
train a neural network that
mimic the behavior of that
you know the differential equations and
we then we use that neural network to
generate the predictions
and compare that against the ground
truth which
you know are the ones that produced from
the differential equation
so it's not surprising there's a like a
deficiency in the accuracy here
yeah so that's pretty much for the
efficiency
and also to explore like like a broader
impact of this work
we also compared our proposed
architecture
against some state-of-the-art
architectures nowadays
for example the lstm network the echo
state network
which is more like a reservoir computing
and
also the clockwork rnn
and we compare them against the sequence
generation task
so the sequence generation task is
basically
we feed the data to different
architectures of the network
we train them and then once it is
trained we feed that network
with the initial snapshot of some sort
of sequence
and we want that network to regenerate
the whole sequence
that's what we mean by sequence
generation
and here uh what i'm going to show you
are basically like four videos so we
have a video sequence of
flower blooming and we want to see like
for different
architectures uh how they're gonna
reproduce this sequence
and this hist basically represents the
hierarchical time stepper
which is the proposed architecture in
this work
and you can see for this hierarchical
timestampers it can almost
perfectly perfectly reproduce like the
sequence
the video sequence but for the lstm
it does like a poor job and also the
same happens for the echo state network
and the clock work on the end but the
key here is not really
about like this competition because we
really adapt like
different philosophy when we try to
do this kind of sequence generation in
the
hierarchical time stepper we're
basically coupling explicitly coupling
different scale neural networks
but for all these others they are
basically recurrent neural net network
they relies on some non-trivial dynamics
which might give you some sort of memory
using the gating mechanism like to you
know to
alleviate like the exploding vanishing
gradient design
pro the gradient problem so yeah this is
one of the examples that we've shown
in this paper and there are also a bunch
of other examples
including the fluid dynamics the chaotic
chaos equation
and also some audio sequences which you
can basically
uh see them in this like the the below
this link
this is like a youtube link which gives
you other examples there
okay so to summarize uh in this work
we have proposed a multi-scale
hierarchical time stepper
it has several advantages it is highly
accurate
because we reduce the error accumulation
problem
and it is highly efficient it can be
paralyzed in nature
and it is highly flexible because it can
be jointly used with the numerical time
steppers
to promote the efficiency of classical
numerical algorithms
and in the end it's also easy to train
when you train each
individual neural network you only need
to focus on its own range of interest
you don't need to trend very far from
the future
this will circumvent like the gradient
exploding and vanishing problem yeah
okay i think that's pretty much it
thanks for listening